the coronavirus of course is for schools
in at least 39 states to close affecting
more than 42 million kindergartner
kindergarten through 12th graders that's
a lot of kids teachers and students are
now trying to adapt to this new normal
with online classes and a lot of video
chats yeah that's right and many parents
are finding themselves teaching kids at
the kitchen table without much support
Salman Khan is founder of Khan Academy
it's a nonprofit organization that
offers free educational content online I
have used it myself and I recommend it
he joins us from Mountain View
California Saul good morning we one of
our colleagues Rina 9:00 and posted a
picture recently of her two kids who's
or their school is shot but every
morning they get dressed put their
backpacks on and pretend that they're on
the bus yes it's great just to
psychologically prepare themselves for
the classroom experience which is at the
kitchen table so you've any other tips
for how parents and kids can get
motivated when they're going to school
we're not going anywhere yeah this is
the first I've heard about the pretend
bus it's a good idea but I think that's
exactly the right idea the more that
students can get into a schedule that
they get up in the morning have their
breakfast again on the same time frame
and you know what I've told parents is a
lot of parents are stressing out
including in my own house have three
kids and what I've told all of them is
you know give yourself a break focus on
the basics if your child or pretty much
any age is at least able to focus on
math and reading two hours a day that's
a great start but then there are the
resources available we're free we're
nonprofit there's other resources where
students are able to have a whole
schedule and that's why we published
some schedules over the weekend for any
age from 4 to 18 to to structure those
days so I've got a college students son
who's taking classes on his bed now and
I've got a wife who's a teacher who's
trying to figure out how to teach kids
reading from from our living room so I
think so many people are not used to
this and overwhelmed by it what's the
best of what you're used to it what's
the best approach so the way I would do
it is I would not recommend the learn
from bread better from bet approach what
I would recommend is start the day
strong I actually like that that model
of pretend you're on the bus
but then you know in our schedules
depending on the age group we start with
a little bit of math while the brain is
fresh make sure to put breaks in there
make sure especially at this time of
social distancing that the students have
a chance to at least run around in the
house or dance or do something have some
physical activity ideally they'll be
able to go outside but then structure
the entire day like that and what you
find is as long as you build that habit
it's not about just doing it all at once
and doing eight hours of learning and
that everyone's all tired it's about
keeping that consistency because this is
likely to last for a little bit and so
if you're not getting direction from
your child's school during this time
what subjects do you think people should
prioritize yeah that's why we exist you
know Khan Academy is a not-for-profit we
could have never foreseen this
eventualities been building content from
pre-k with Khan Academy kids and reading
writing and social-emotional learning in
math and then the rest of Khan Academy
goes all the way through middle school
high school includes math English
language arts history sciences and we
have free SAT prep that we've partnered
with the College Board and that's
reading writing and mathematics and so I
would focus if you just have to focus on
one thing I would do an hour of reading
and that could be as simple as reading a
book and on our schedules we've
published some book lists for students
of different ages and then I would I
would make sure to get that math because
those are two skills if they don't
atrophy your students are going to be
just fine and I would also encourage
please consider continue during the
summer so that you know whatever habits
you're forming now can can keep up but
then as those students have those basics
and they're feeling like they're getting
those two subjects layer on the rest of
the school day because the resources are
there they're free and there's also ways
that teachers and parents can keep track
of what the students are doing so dear
classes also work for for parents
themselves they may need to learn math
before they're teaching it differently
now the ohm at math is not hard if math
is not hard it's just a mindset okay
[Laughter]
what would you what you just described
is actually a best practice if parents
can model that learning with the student
especially for younger students if you
learn alongside them a lot of times a
parent might be embarrassed that they
forgot their fifth grade fractions as
you mentioned but I think there's no
better signal to your students to say
hey you know what I forgot that let's
learn that together let's watch the
video let's do some exercises together
your kids will really appreciate that
yeah we're all going back to school in a
way Sal Khan thank you very much for
being with us this morning